here with reaction are friend Fox and
Friends Weekend co-host Volcan Fox News
contributed Joe Concha uh Joe uh the way
the media is going to cover this race
how do you see it because obviously they
hate Trump but they're now showing they
hate DeSantis too and they hate
basically anybody that is a Republican
and they will try to slander smear uh
besmirch all of them
sure and Sean guys like Chris Christie
and my former Governor they're going to
be leading the pack in terms of that
criticism in terms of being the pit bull
so he's going to get a lot of air time
but Chris Christie needs a DeLorean and
and 1.21 gigawatts at this point because
his time to run was back in time in 2012
when he was a popular no not nonsense
Governor obviously when he left office
all that love went away so now he's
doing this just to be a disrupter at
this point but look we're 245 days away
or something from the Iowa caucuses and
the first primary debate is more than 60
days away and I'm not sure you're going
to see much movement from any of the
other GOP candidates including Ron
DeSantis until we get to that first
debate because we can be looking at an
audience of 20 million people or more
just like we saw in 2015. and if
DeSantis can perform well there perhaps
that's where the momentum can come from
but until it's a two-man race Trump's
going to hold one big piece of the pie
and then the other eight or nine ten
candidates they're going to split the
other piece the question is will
candidates that are pulling at 3 percent
four percent hang on through Iowa New
Hampshire Nevada South Carolina or will
they do the right thing and drop out
since they have no shot and then we'll
really see for the first time the
contrast between Trump and DeSantis and
maybe then DeSantis has a puncher's
chance but when you see 31 point lead
right there boy it's hard to see the guy
who got 74 million votes in 2020 somehow
that lead dissipating to a point where
DeSantis is a true true threat as it
stands right now you know will I have no
problem giving air time to any of the
candidates who want to come on and give
their point of view but I'm looking at
Chris Christie he left office as
governor of New Jersey 13 approval
rating 14 on another poll and I'm
looking at this and I'm saying okay
you're only getting in this race because
you hate Donald Trump and want to
bludgeon Donald Trump I don't see Chris
Christie uh actually wanting to run and
win the nomination he views it as his
role to be the enforcer and to attack
Trump you know what that's not a very
inspiring agenda and I don't even know
if I'm interested in facilitating or
listening to you know him Babylon when
he left office with nobody in New Jersey
even liking him
yeah like you Sean I'm interested in
hearing from almost every candidate I
want to hear what their case is to make
America a better place tomorrow but I
honestly Sean don't see a path
for any of the alternative candidates to
Donald Trump and that includes Ron
DeSantis interestingly to Joe's point I
bet you Chris Christie serves as an
inspiration for Rhonda Sanderson
choosing to run in this election cycle
because there's this Maxim you've got to
go when it's your time and many people
feel Chris Christie missed his time
there's some sentiment I imagine around
Ron DeSantis that we've been successful
in Florida and now is our time but the
public doesn't seem to be buying it Sean
and right now I don't see anything
including you know Joe's right we don't
know what could happen in a debate but
if I'm just putting my bets down on the
table I don't think a debate is going to
change the calculus on this polling
we've seen Donald Trump in debates he
wins debates so the only thing that I
can explain for anyone's path including
Christy or Pence is they're expecting
some potential bomb to drop I don't know
what that could be Sean an investigation
who knows what it may be because Donald
Trump has survived all of those as well
but they're waiting for some bomb to
explode and then one of the others
emerge from the chaos all right thank
you both when we come back hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else